plusieurs militants du collectif
identitaire nemesis sont rassemblés ce
matin sur la place du trocadéro à paris
afin de dénoncer la journée mondiale de
jijel
c'est pourtant avec un niqab un voile
intégral et que les quelques femmes du
collectif
revendiquant une idéologie féministe
identitaires ont déambulé sur le parvis
du trocadéro à paris
leur protestation fait donc écho à la
journée mondiale des fusées pts et au
radiothon de 3 février prochain la porte
parole du collectif alice cordier a été
arrêté peu après le début du
rassemblement rtl interrogé le sens de
notre action aujourd'hui était de
dénoncer le hidjab dès qu'il ya un
concept international qui vise à se
voiler en soutien aux femmes musulmanes
se serait martyrisé en france et en
europe
aujourd'hui nous nous préférons rendre
hommage aux femmes qui essayait
d'enlever leur voile notamment dans les
pays du moyen-orient et du maghreb
justement en dénonçant ce qu'est le
voile intégral en montrant qu'on pensait
être ce voile aussi peut arriver et que
c'est une catastrophe de voir que les
yeux des femmes que ce n'est pas du tout
dans nos principes républicains ni
européen ni d'ailleurs si on ne fait pas
partie de notre culture et nous nous
préférons rendre hommage à ces femmes là
qui justement sont martyrisés tous les
jours on a beaucoup de cas de femme
défigurée à l'acide de femmes
emprisonnées sur des années 150 ans
parfois même pour les plus activistes
d'entre elles et nous avons voulu
dénoncer cela aujourd'hui en montrant
que oui les françaises aussi peut-être
peut-être un jour voilées intégralement
et que ce n'est pas souhaitable